so yesterday we played this instantly
viral video for you of one of Donald
Trump's lifetime would be lifetime
appointees to be a federal judge his
name is Matthew Spencer Peterson let's
just that there's nothing better than
just reminding you what took place
during this guy's confirmation hearing
where he just didn't know anything about
the job he was going to have here's one
quick example as I've been a party to
during my time yes sir I've read your
resume
just for the record do you know what
emotion in women he is I would probably
not be able to give you a good
definition probably do you know what the
younger abstention doctrine is again
about the Pullman abstention doctrine I
don't see you all see that a lot in
federal court so anyway he's dropped out
the scandal that exploded over this
totally abortive confirmation hearing
testimony he is the third judicial
Selection from Trump to drop after it
just became completely obvious that he
has no business being a judge appointed
for life to an important position or
even an unimportant position I would
argue he is withdrawn his name he says
he's withdrawing because he doesn't want
to become a distraction that's that's
one way to say it another one would be
that he's withdrawn after it became
abundantly clear that he shouldn't be a
federal judge and I'm still getting
emails from uninformed and you know it's
okay that they're uninformed but maybe
inform yourself before emailing me I'm
getting emails from people who wrongly
believe that the questions posed to mr.
Peterson were sort of obscure difficult
gotcha questions I got a voicemail about
this too from Troy York who says
basically this exact same thing listen
to it David Pakman you are Appa's ass
you're making fun of that law candidate
a walk and it was grilled all them
stupid questions there can be millions
of questions of all how would you like
it if you were as a Senate hearing
trying to get a job as a podcast or at
MSNBC
and they're asking you all these
economic terms is that it okay and then
we're not mixing finance that you have
long forgotten and studied from your
days of tooling under professor Richard
Wolffe that's right Richard Wolffe was
my professor at Boston College yeah but
that was that that was at UMass Troy
you're wrong I mean these are not
obscure legal questions right countless
law professors including and aderson
Francois from Georgetown Law School he
said any second-year law student never
mind a second-year lawyer would have
better answers to these questions than
the ones that Peterson had and remember
that the focus only became Peterson
during the hearing because there was a
question asked has anyone on the on this
panel never tried a trial to verdict or
given a deposition on your own and
Peterson raised his hand and he was the
only one so had he even been involved in
one trial he would have avoided at least
some of that scrutiny by not being the
one dude on the panel raising his hand
it's because of him that all of this
happened it has nothing to do with
senator Kennedy or me or anyone at MSNBC
yeah maybe some of these second year law
students would have made better
candidates than this guy apparently no
doubt about it yeah at least they would
have been able to give some answer to
what a motion in limine is I mentioned
yesterday that some Trumpets think this
is good right nominees like this are
good in the same way that they saw
Trump's political lack of experience as
good they say hey this guy's lack of
judicial experience is good it's been a
disaster with Trump number one but the
logic of it is fundamentally flawed as a
principle that the idea is Outsiders
make refreshingly good candidates for
many fields would you support an airline
pilot with no flying experience because
you want new energy in the cockpit would
you support a lifelong librarian I don't
know to be your dental hygienist because
you're sick and tired of these career
dental hygienists that only know one way
of doing things obviously not so once
you have a counterexample to the
principal you then have to think about
each instance and there's nothing about
math you spend
Peterson that makes him a good candidate
for a lifetime judicial appoint and why
would you support a president who had no
experience in public service as well yes
my favorite Trump appointee for a
judgeship was the guy who was a ghost
hunter and a lien writer and he was
deemed not qualified by the American Bar
Association and Peterson was also deemed
unqualified by the way the and that guy
dropped out as well right that's one of
the three it's that guy Peterson and I
think one other that dropped out yeah
just it just it's a gong show of bizarre
nominations